yeah welcome to this video playing mi
arenas from minutes villa i hope so
colombia I ok so we transpose back to a
Sicilian started as a French but let's
go for the con variation always
interesting ok please sir may be going
for the English attack which isn't
really a good line against the car
because of exactly that did some quite
remarkable that you get this against an
I am it's a really am well known that
you cannot play the English attack
against the car the problem is that
there's so much I cannot drive us I
wanted to draw arrows in the middle of
the game of course that's not possible
um the the problem is the the the big
instant pressure on on the center and
immediately when you for here the the
issue also being with the damage pawn
structure that um I'll wait wait wait
not so quick
maybe I haven't ok just guess is ok with
the damaged bone structure can never
castle long of course I go b5 well you
will go to be three ok maybe what he ate
I am Bishop g5 I haven't fine ok so
after up dat probably yeah needs to need
to mr. Queen and now I was thinking
about Knight to g5 which is some quite
annoying the bishop is hanging Bishop g5
AG 0 FF 6 and that I can play III
resigns actually I think what what is he
doing now rope hanging right hanging and
had the Queen trade so almost resigns
okay so taking or hmm I could also think
about night f4 look bad if i just take
on 1 c 2
just grab that before before he is able
to play pawn to c4 at a later stage and
and get rid of my night I'm just
grabbing all the porns so
okay so how many points is that just to
question is how to set up the pieces
it's just a develop first I can always I
can always use D 5 D 5 is a very nice
square for the night I'm not sure that I
want to take on the one yeah okay I need
to need to kick this this away
ok
mmm I hope this really wins material
either like a plan a deformity there are
all kinds of things are hanging I hey
now if you moves the night to some
neutral square take a for it takes sc6
luck c6 it is important that this night
is preventing look the one moves Group C
1 because of the fork um this is
actually a big problem I think he has to
go 94 then I just take it probably and
play oh I took them didn't expect that
ok need to recapture what else ok
so you still cannot move move the rocks
and I want to control g4 here threaten
bishop is 6mb should be six coming yeah
check yeah the sorcerer was helpful
check
ya know its own it's even an additional
exchange that got lost check let's see
that I don't get back ranked chanted
place or resign other fees yeah this was
an opening really an opening disaster
and it's it simply it's just like that
the English attack with f3 and queen
YouTube it's not playable against the
calm so it's just this exactly this year
it's for white this is just a disaster
for why'd you lose material in the
center arm get get an awful structure
this is also i was losing the e porn and
after that they're just various ways to
get a baguette I mean this is probably
one of them yeah this is flat-out
winning maybe even had something better
but other computers actually giving my
mousse kundi three is supposed to
supposed to even better but ok but what
else it's at the moment here three extra
points and and an overwhelming position
so this 195 yeah of course I can just
play 95 yeah yeah I don't look that okay
it keeps it keeps a very big Mukesh and
probably also win some butter put a
check check midlife somewhat easier yeah
just like that this opening still able
to set up against the car thanks for
watching